now during our first interview um we had
a a crafty halfway through and that
was when the that was when the real
interview happened wasn't it
Professor because I'm not sure what are
you allowed to show this kind of thing
on oh I don't know these days I do know
on the BBC they are allowing more
smoking back slowly are they yes and
remember it's never too late to
start I mean ironically can't give you
cancer although it does protect protect
from Parkinson's disease than Co so oh
and and it's better than
[Laughter]
vaping so yeah we're we're currently in
a uh a country
pile north of London we're near U is
this Hartford sh it is yes yes the most
um Eastern extent I would imagine so
within six minutes of the M25 is
absolutely amazing you know yes yes and
in a couple of weeks I'll be coming over
to your house car cuz we have a
conversation with Steven wolf yes yes
have you thought about what you're going
to um discuss with I have actually I I
didn't realize you were coming today but
by coincidence last night I suddenly
realized all my to-do lists were getting
very
condensed figuring prominently on that
to-do list is to is to watch uh Steven's
interview and I promise to read his
favorite paper back I I think what I I
deliberately won't I deliberately won't
because the audience I think will
probably want to have his ideas exposed
uh online so if I go in there with a
with a
I I go
there with the same the same
um Earnest and interested naivity as the
audience will have I think that will
probably be be better but I I will I
will certainly I I actually dedicated
Sunday afternoon to to uh doing my
homework and getting up to speed with um
wolf Run's Notions and uh most recent
book yes my my take on it is I think um
you and Steph have um a very specific
private language so there's there's the
Frisian language and there's the Wolfram
language and I think the the challenge
is when when when you have your level of
expertise in something you semantically
attach an understanding a meaning to
words and I think it's very difficult to
imagine what it it's like to not have
the generative model underlying those
words yes and it's going back to First
principle because um Steven does tend to
say oh it's the ruad it's the you know
what I mean just and to him that that
that invokes so much richness of
understanding but it doesn't necessarily
in in the in the other side of the
conversation I can't remember whether it
was you
um but certainly he was he was obliged
to explain and Define every one of his
NE neologist
at the point that they occurred and I
recognize that pathology in certainly
myself uh and uh in one sense um you
know I think that explains why people
like me and possibly him um have a
reputation for being completely uh
impenetrable uh yes uh I think unjustly
so I I think there's a Simplicity to his
ideas and a truth there uh as in the
same um sense that the freey principle
is such such a simple almost tological
statement but to convey the Simplicity
is extremely hard and I usually rely
upon people who are much better
wordsmiths so I'm not going to write a
book whereas he he actually committed to
to his own book because he's talking
about the theory of observers and I
think there is something very
fundamental about an agent and this is
something which is woven into the core
of your formalism will you be able to
steid well um Maxwell is unwell so Keith
will be the moderator okay so I'm going
to film it on your end and then Keith
will moderate okay yeah yeah so um and
and feel free to have a chat with Keith
beforehand oh no I'm I'm very um
complacent confident that he he'll I'll
be in a safe Pair of Hands oh definitely
definitely we we're we're orchestrating
this epic session with with friston and
Wolfram in a couple of weeks time and um
I was going to comment that um you know
what it's like you're carrying heavy
camera equipment you're nervous because
you're talking to your intellectual Idol
I mean I was just in in a country pile
having a crafty with Professor Carl
friston so um my mind wasn't exactly
exploding with incredibly intelligent um
comments to make but we were talking
about this upcoming uh conversation with
Wolfram and I think what I wanted to
articulate essentially is that Wolfram
and friston come at this from two
different levels of resolution they both
emergentists wolm thinks that the
universe is made out of tiny little
discrete bits and he's got this
essentially like a a graph cellular
automaton view of the universe of which
from everything emerges and friston has
this perspective lens which encodes
agents at the very core right and this
lens is quite abstract because it can be
nested so you can have agents inside a
agents inside agents in fact depending
on your interpretation the lens can also
be Observer relative so you can see
agents that possibly other agents can't
see so it's it's a little bit vague but
what I want to get to though is what are
you losing by going to that level of
abstraction so you're introducing agents
in everything you see and what does that
give you and what does it take away yeah
well first I I I have a slightly
different view I think because um I
really don't think that that much in
terms of Agents I mean I think it's it's
okay to call like things agents but I
think the more General perspective of
the free energy principle is is we're
talking about subsystems you know and
there's this definition of a subsystem
which is that it's it's defined by a
marob blanket and so I think uh if you
take say you take wolf Rams you know
ruad right and this and this
incomprehensibly vast system right I
mean just
incomprehensibly fast right because
we're not even talking about you know 10
to the 8th particles in the universe
we're talking about some some substrate
layer that's even even orders many many
orders of magnitude below that right so
it's just incomprehensibly vast system
and I think the free energy principle
says you know has no conflict with that
it's just how do you now
organize that incomprehensibly vast
system in some way and it says says well
well we we divide it up into subsystems
we divide it up into these
non-equilibrium steady state subsystems
defined by a Marco blanket and they can
be nested and there can be marov
blankets that cross each other and
intersect and all kinds of things but
it's about finding those non-equilibrium
steady state
things right and um and and of course
some things um reach a sufficient level
of complexity say a person where they
they do now behave as agents in the
sense that they have um they behave as
if they had intentions and goals and and
beliefs and and are conducting active
inference about the world uh because I
think like the free energy folks would
claim if you don't conduct active
inference at that level of complexity
you you do not continue to exist you
know yeah well okay so that's quite
deflationary that's a very non-nonsense
interpretation
and that is literally what the free
energy principle is it's it's talking
about this equilibrium of of a system
into things what are things and what are
not things and how do those kind of um
coales over time but you know maybe then
we should bring in to to what extent is
this just a cognitive assist for us
right so we've spoken about the
intentional stance and that is a frame
of mind that helps us predict what other
things are doing more accurately and
philosophers talk about phenomenology
and the hard problem and again this is
it's just a frame of mind that helps us
point to things to talk about things and
to understand each other and as the
Things become more complicated it makes
sense for us to think about them as
agents because they act in their
environment and again going back to
Elizabeth Spell's cognitive prior or
core knowledge she calls it um an agent
is one of those core things so we
understand agents we understand things
that act and share information in their
physical environment that makes a lot of
sense to us and then the question is
well to what extent is it just a a tool
for our shared understanding both in
terms of communication and thinking and
did we inherit this cognitive tool from
the natural world in the way that
Chomsky alludes to when he talks about
this laws of nature imbus us with this
core
knowledge yeah but but what what what
exactly is the question though like I'm
wondering well well the the question
okay so I guess this this is quite a
general point and I was discussing this
with Jeff Beck as well which is that you
can model cognitive systems at many
levels of abstraction and intuitively
the primordial level seems like the best
because it's the most robust so um
Wolfram I think is the most primordial
level he's modeling the the atoms of the
univer by atoms I mean the most
fundamental things in the universe
and friston is kind of saying okay well
let's not mandate the highest possible
resolution let's have a view where
agents or Things become a fundamental
and then um GOI people go one level
higher and they explicitly model goals
and even at friston's level he's
explicitly modeling the existence
imperative so even though they're all
universalists at every single level on
that ladder you're making a statement
that you think a particular thing is
universal yeah I don't I mean I think um
probably the only level at which people
are really making a universal statement
is is at this you know most fundamental
fundamental level right because we
believe yeah where there's only one
universe and at some fine enough scale
um uh it's the same everywhere or has
the same components and the same laws
you know hopefully maybe who knows maybe
some distant part of the universe has
slightly different laws I don't know but
I think uh at the at the higher levels I
don't think typically people make
Universal claims like for example
consider a level of psychology right I
don't think anybody would say human
psychology applies to you know dogs
maybe some aspects of it do but but
maybe they don't and obviously
psychology doesn't apply at all to your
thermostat or a um you know a robot even
though those may have other properties
of of Agents like some intentions or
some you know model of the world that
type of thing and then the other
Universal is this uh free energy
principle right but that only applies to
these certain types of of although very
common these certain types of
non-equilibrium steady state um systems
right so and and I also like there is no
best level I think people always
probably think like whatever level they
work on is is the best level you know
like a a physicist will will say uh no
every everything is just uh physics you
know even chemistry is is physics too
sure but you know we have a separate
science for a reason right because there
are these you know higher level laws
these emergent laws whether they're
strongly emergent weakly emergent
doesn't matter they still are laws that
you have to figure out and until you
come up with a way to figure them out
from quantum mechanics which you can't
currently do we have to do some other
other mechanism right some other type of
Science and
abduction that that makes sense but I
guess like I'm saying in any kind of
model there's an infinite number of
possible models and when we settle on a
model and the model will make certain
assumptions about the domain we live in
um you know that there are let's say
discrete particles in the universe or
that there is such a thing as an
existential imperative or there is such
a thing as a goal and it just feels like
at some point when you come up with your
model you you're making a claim that
these things are Universal well you're
not I mean I mean that that isn't what
you're doing I think I think Jeff Beck
made this point kind of very clearly
which is sure there's an infinite number
of models we obviously can't explore an
infinite space so we explore a finite
space and he paraphrased Einstein right
and said uh all models are wrong and and
some are really bad and like we don't
want to use the really bad ones so I
don't think you know I'm sure some
people believe that if they come up with
a model it's Universal but I think
like I think people that are a bit more
circumspect or or pragmatic realize it's
never Universal you know there is the
you know Universal truths are
exceedingly rare like vanishingly you
know rare uh all models are provisional
they're all wrong and some Way Or
Another We're just we have we're we can
only consider a finite set of models and
we hope that um they're uh you know not
too wrong as to be unuseful
right yeah no I I agree with that I mean
of course we we often discuss that math
does not represent talk by Eric Cel so
I'm I'm not saying in any way that the
the formalism is universal I'm just
saying it's used as if it is univ so
when we view everything in terms of the
free energy principle we're never
changing the free energy principle to
view things differently we're taking it
no I get what you're saying now which is
that and I think that's part of the
scientific process which is that you
come up with a model and then you're
right you you do behave
you you act as if it's Universal um
really only so you can find places where
it fails and then when you find places
where it fails that's where you can you
can learn more so I think that's part of
the the scientific process but I I would
hope even people when they're acting as
if it's Universal they know it's not
they're just they're just doing it
because they're looking for areas where
it fails so they can expand you know the
knowledge Rising further they can refine
the model more they can come up with a a
new model they can figure out in what
regime reg that applies and which it
doesn't yeah absolutely well just coming
on to um wol again because you're you're
going to be moderating the conversation
now and obviously you can talk a little
bit I'm petrified man like moderating
this oh I'm I'm not I'm not surprised
but but we were just saying though that
if Wolfram wants to have a theory of of
observers now I I I have a bit of a
psychology lens on things I I think it's
because we understand how agents work
and it helps us kind of visualize and
think about and reason about things but
is there more to it I think in I think
in Wolf Ren's case he's making a very
deep um computational point which is
that um any particular Observer by
necessity is is computationally bound
and that and that therefore because
there are these computational bounds uh
and they're trying to model um they're
trying to model with under the
constraint rather of that that
computational boundedness it has certain
has certain consequences and and those
consequences are are quite interesting
like he makes the case that you know say
the phenomenon of entropy you know is a
or possibly if I understand correctly is
a consequence of of trying to do this
computationally bounded you know
modeling of of a system that's far
beyond your scale right and other things
could be that way too time you know the
perception of time maybe is um these
types of phenomenon that that are really
U derived from the fact that or derived
from the fact that you're a
computationally bounded Observer of this
as we said earlier incompr
incomprehensibly vast you know substrate
right I remember now reading his book
you're you're absolutely right right so
a lot of this is around the broader
theme of computational ir it's it's you
know what's really interesting about it
is because you and I have talked a lot
over the years in the show about this
almost unreasonable effectiveness of
abstraction the unreasonable
effectiveness of of math you know why do
we have these Ultra simple models and
equations you know with um uh continuous
quantities that we don't even know maybe
not even exist and yet they somehow or
another uh
seem to describe and predict the
Universe um well enough that we can that
we can do a lot of interesting things
like they're they're very very useful
right and that to me is you know this
big mystery as to why that even why that
even works and I think a lot of the I
think a lot of wolfram's work um is
maybe leading us towards you know very
uh concrete answers to those
questions yeah and we've spoken about
many different lens is for things by the
way in the in the last two weeks I've
heard about 20 different descriptions of
what a Transformer is and we have about
10 different descriptions of what
intelligence is and and the underlying
theme Here is complexity right it's
because it's very very complex and we're
an observer and we have a certain
perspective on on things and
interestingly enough the the complexity
lens is one of the one of the most high
resolution lens to understand everything
including intelligence you can say that
intelligence is actually about
navigating complexity and actually one
of the reasons why Agent Frameworks and
active inference I think work so well is
because it's a more efficient way of
tackling the complexity in our in our
lived world than a monolithic neural
network and in in that sense I think
Wolf's really on to something by viewing
everything in terms of
complexity yeah and and
complexity uh and I'm and folks again
you know it's I'm not an expert on on
complexity science and and Ma math um so
I don't know what the state-ofthe-art is
in it but my understanding is that it's
it's it's been a frontier for a long
time and and remains a frontier you know
it's this field of math and science
that's uh I guess really hard for for
human beings to to deal with in in our
kind of cognitive Horizon if you will so
I'm always fascinated by people who are
trying to make progress um on complexity
Theory and you know I don't know I have
no idea what's going to come out of it
but I I think it's
fascinating beautiful so um just closing
thoughts what is your game plan oh my
game plan so the problem is you know
these these are two both
extremely brilliant people um with vast
knowledge uh in in their in their fields
and like you know I've I said to you
once um look we you know hey hey we're
we're producing YouTube videos and
podcasts right so we're going to get
hate from time to time and I never I
never care about if other people think
I'm stupid now that's fine like so what
maybe I am like I'm okay that's fine but
if I think I'm stupid if I think I'm
stupid then I would be a bit more
annoyed and these are these are two
people who uh who absolutely like I I am
afraid they're going to make me think
I'm I'm stupid you know not because they
meant to but just because it's it's just
such towering intellects and knowledge
so what's the plan you know I I really
hope to kind of in the spirit of
steering emergence I hope to steer a
little bit um them towards an
interaction with each other that that
our viewers really really enjoy and that
you and I and our viewers um can learn a
lot from so I don't know yet how I'm
going to do that that's always tricky
how do you steer an emergent system but
I'll I'll definitely be putting a lot of
work work in between now and and the
recording date to try and Achieve that
that
goal yeah and intelligence is such a
fascinating thing because um I I was
speaking with friston about his frisoni
and language it's it's quite obscure and
of course Wolfram has has um a very
distinctive language he uses as well
which belies all of this complexity but
I guess like the the ironic thing is
that someone who's not versed in all of
these Concepts might look at um friston
and Wolfram and just think oh they're
just talking rubbish and it might it
might even seem like it's not
intelligent discourse and you you almost
need to have a certain cognitive Horizon
even to understand how incredibly
brilliant these two men are yeah but you
know what it it's worth the effort for
those that that want to put into it to
um understand the the semantics that
they're attaching you know to the the
words and the concepts that they're
using uh I've certainly found that to be
the case is that oh 100% you know
walking into into it like a lot of the
um you know the recordings that we do
right with friston or Wolfram I mean at
the time I can barely understand what's
being said maybe not even understand
what's being said you know and then of
course we got a tag team thing going on
which is cool because because then you
can take over for a bit and I can think
about digest a bit but I find myself
watching the videos back a couple of
times and again and again thinking about
it because you almost have to listen a
minute or two pause it think about it
maybe do some little bit of research but
I think it's worth it you know I think
both I think both Wolfram and friston
are working on absolutely
fascinating um you know work theories
that are that are on the edge of of what
we know and I think they will have as
well practical consequences in the in
the decades and probably centuries you
know to come so I think it's worth
taking the time to try and understand
it
yeah exactly and and um this uh we we
read a delip George article before we
interviewed Melanie Mitchell and I know
I've said this a few times but it it it
really moved me this idea that we have
the Matrix going on in our heads and you
know Nagle said you don't know what it's
like to experience being a bat or indeed
being wol or friston can you only
imagine the kind of cinematic experience
that they must have going on inside
their heads and all we have are these
words that they speak and when we
communicate we are just kind of trying
to shape reality trying to bend our
simulations to have even some of the
Fidelity that they have but it's just
remarkable just to think of what it must
be like to be those two yeah um but look
it's fun it's fun to try and think like
that and it's fun to try and figure that
out so uh yeah this is going to be fun
I'm looking forward to it I'll do the
best I
can uh and and I think we're going to
get a an enjoyable emergent conversation
out of the two of
them it certainly will be emergent
anyway cheers Keith yeah so that video
is coming out in a couple of
weeks photos of the Rich and
Famous
absolutely so a lot of my um hero from
the television the movies are here it's
incredible to and not quite Heroes but
certainly some of the good and great
from uh
politics and the landed
gentry inspector Mor he's a favorite
around the world oh
yes sadly deceased
now it always amuses me that Americans
love inspector
Moos they must think that the all of
England is just like Oxford yes yes
only a minor extrapolation car Alan
Bates can you remember the famous films
no you'll have no give me an example no
you'll have to in
Wikipedia pet to incredible Leo mccar
the prisoner Ah that's probably before
your time isn't it yes that was
groundbreaking
existential crisis in a little um
Italian eight Village in North Wales was
used to film it yes and the poor guy
Patrick mcon I think um a spy I think
was secluded there and had to work out
why he was there and it was a very
surreal and I I remember my father used
to love it and I used to used to sort
of I empathized completely with this you
know with his love of this series I
think there only about six episodes and
he just wanted to find out why was he
there and what was going to happen to
him at the end and the final episode
everybody that I knew in the UK was
glued to the television to find out what
happened to the
prisoner I won't tell you you might you
might want to watch it